you always think come on how can someone
get brainwashed well you know
working with i haven't really talked
about this but like working with allison
and seeing her grow up and uh
you know i never really hung out with
her maybe a couple cast dinners and you
know
directed her and she was really sweet
and you know she
yeah she was always really nice needed
attention who doesn't i know i do
and you know there were certain things
um but you ask yourself how does
someone just
completely it's almost like you you're
leaving your skin
somewhere and you're i i can't explain
it because
knowing allison for those years and just
sitting around sitting but you know i
never you never imagined a million years
that's why i think i neglected
sort of uh to read about it or really
it's like
this can't be there's got to be
something
but you probably saw her change
i did and and when you first met her
because
you know it is it's still hard for me to
believe i mean there was an incident at
my house
um years later um still
i don't know if i was on so i don't
think i was on smallville but she
and a friend of hers and this guy said
hey i'm gonna talk to you forever we
want to stop by
and i hadn't seen her and they walked in
the house
and it was almost like i i just remember
i'm not being
uh i'm not blowing this out of
proportion i'm not exaggerating at all i
remember because my friend ethan was
here
and i remember we just kind of go and i
didn't by the way i didn't even know
about this
next team or anything at this point i
mean i remember on set once
she came and she was like hey you should
take this class it's really cool and
blah blah
and i remember i said to tom sounds like
a cult i don't know and we kind of
laughed but we never thought oh it's
like you know
i'm sure it's like people are looking
for things we never did it but i never
but but after that
you know we never really heard about it
it just she that was what she was doing
and i never really thought about it
so years later i don't know what year
this is i i have to go back and i could
probably figure it out
but i think it was after smallville she
you know she's in the vicinity she comes
over the house
and she walks in and she walked in
she was a different person she walked in
like she owned my house
like literally she owned my home
she walked in with her friends and they
walked into the kitchen i was like hey
she was like hey how are you and then
walked into my kitchen started bringing
out pots and pans and started cooking i
go
uh what are you guys doing my friend
ethan's like
it's like we're hungry we're hungry
we're we're gonna we're gonna i remember
that like it was yesterday
i got to talk to ethan because then
i said after a while i just felt
uncomfortable i was like well hey guys
you know
uh like that's it come on you know let's
you know it's
and i kind of asked them like hey you
know you might want to leave soon and i
was going to be nice
the guy turned almost violent he was
violent like he
wasn't he i can't remember who what his
name i know because i didn't care i just
was like who the [ __ ] is this guy
very angry and like just i think he was
on something
he was like and he just started kind of
cursing at me and ethan i was like [ __ ]
you i'm like you know what buddy i don't
know what this is about you just come in
you start cooking in my house
you guys don't even say why don't you
guys just go why i actually like you to
get the [ __ ] out of my house
that's what i said and i remember i was
waiting for allison to sort of jump in
and say i'm so sorry no no he doesn't
mean this
there was nothing it was just like it
was almost like they were zombies that's
how i remember i'll never forget it
and i'm not saying that that the this
has anything to do with next thing i was
going to do it
but when they left i looked at ethan and
we were hearts were racing and i'm like
oh my god i'm disgusted i i don't you
know and i remember i got a text maybe a
few days later
oh sorry about the other night or
something i don't it's bizarre
but i'm just telling you that i i don't
know where it came from i don't know
what happened
maybe it was a bad night but it was
years after i had seen her hadn't seen
her for a long time so i think what i'm
saying is
did you when you first met her to the
time all this [ __ ] went down
what was that transformation like what
was that sort of relationship
i mean i'm going to backtrack for one
sec because you said something about
brainwashing
and it's important that people
you know either either you're of the
mind of like
we're all brainwashed it's just another
word is indoctrinated we're
indoctrinated by society by our parents
to believe certain things
you know commercials and doctrine in us
we it's it's hap
it's not a matter of whether we're
brainwashed or not just how brainwashed
are you
right that's one belief right right i
didn't understand how this worked until
i left
quick plug for a book that really helped
me understand it's called combating cult
mind control by stephen hassan and it
explains
how in a seminar you can be
indoctrinated
especially in three days that's why by
day three they had me their hooks were
in me
and it goes step by step and i'm not an
expert i can't
even begin to try to explain what he
explains in this book but if people want
to understand
better that happens but for somebody
like allison
and and keep in mind i was there for
some things i wasn't there for other
things
i can only i'm kind of hypothesizing
what happened with her
you know and i also don't want to like
bring any more
hurt on her and her family i want her to
be better i want her to wake up and i
i've heard by the way that she has which
is great
yeah that's that's what i was sort of
hoping i was hoping that like because i
don't know anything other than i just
remember her as a sweet girl and i hope
that i just kept hoping i was wrong or
people were wrong and i just don't know
how it happened so continue sorry you
know what what i remember is from that
first training and i'd met her
casually through a group of friends um
you know at a bar
like at a party super outgoing great
dancer i remember thinking like her
style was really great great singer
great singer really friendly very um i
liked how like she was very touchy
you know lots of hugs um and i really
liked her a lot
and after that first training i think
because she was
um she wasn't working the next day and
she she got on the plane
and went back to albany to meet keith
after two days
and i don't some people said it was like
the
private jet i don't know i don't it's a
rumor it's a private jet or
either way she got on the plane went
back and met keith and that
video footage that you see in the vow of
them meeting at volleyball
like i've never seen that even though
that footage existed when i watched that
two weeks ago i was like
[ __ ] i mean people don't didn't normally
meet keith until you'd have to take a
minimum
16 day so the fact that they let
you know allison into that world and she
felt probably very special
to get special access to the vanguard
i think it's all things that um many of
us
that were you know were our actors like
wanting to be
feel important feel special get
attention um
i think she got all that and and uh that
was after two days
yeah she had well it was a three-day
training in vancouver and she flew back
and and met him and
and i'm sure he's i don't know about you
but i got i mean i felt nauseous i felt
got chills when i saw that video like
how he was looking at her and what he
and what he said to her and
i was he was [ __ ] with her mind and
like
bearing into her soul with his eyes like
you could just see the whole
history unfold
you